wir kennen gerade nur noch ein thema das
kroner virus breitet sich weiter auf
seine therapien schon gar keine impfung
der höhepunkt der ausbreitung ist noch
nicht erreicht
es ist ernst nehmen sie es auch erreicht
aber spulen wir nur mal ein paar wochen
zurück
noch vor zwei monaten war eine andere
krise allgegenwärtig
die klimakrise verursacht schäden in
milliarden höhe logisch lebt die
menschheit von heute an auf der deutsche
städte rufen den klima notstand aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der streit was wir gegen den klimawandel
tun sollen hat unsere gesellschaft immer
stärker gespalten
ich wollte wissen warum das so ist
wollte ihre meinung dazu werden und habe
deshalb über das zdf und die sozialen
medien einen aufruf gestartet
[Musik]
was nervt euch am thema streit
die resonanz war riesig tausende
nachrichten haben mich erreicht über
facebook twitter instagram und penny
was mich an klimastreit nervt dass es
einen gibt
[Musik]
jeder hat ein recht auf eine eigene
meinung aber niemand auf eigene fakten
[Musik]
für uns kleine wird alles teurer die
konzerne dürfen munter weiter ihren
dreck in die umwelt blasen
was mich nervt die hysterie die moral
die religiöse attitüde der protagonisten
das war im februar und märz einige die
mir geschrieben haben habe ich wie immer
gesucht doch dann hat sich während
unserer dreharbeiten alles verändert das
leben steht still
was uns als gesellschaft ins mark trifft
was dem klima aber er hilft kaum mehr
flüge weniger autoverkehr weniger
fabriken in betrieb allein in china 25
prozent weniger co2 ausstößt aber
deshalb ist der klimastreit yannis
becker
wir machen zu wenig wir sind zu träge zu
bequem
das haben wir sehr sehr viele
geschrieben fünf vor zwölf ist längst
vorbei jeder ist gefragt seine
komfortzone zu verlassen und
verantwortung zu übernehmen
wir wollen doch gar nicht viel nur eine
faire chance auf einen lebenswerten
planeten
würde die politik die klimakrise als
solche anerkennen gäbe es gar kein
streit mehr weil alle wissen womit wir
es hier zu tun haben
jaromir schmidt hat mir diese zeilen
geschickt
[Musik]
jaromir lebt in berlin geht in die
zwölfte klasse und ist bei friday is for
future aktiv wegen corona können wir uns
nicht treffen haben uns deshalb zum
skypen verabredet hallo jaromir ich find
dich kennenzulernen
wenn auch nur auf die distanzen jaromir
fordert ja schon seit monaten dass die
politik die krise endlich als krise
wahrnimmt dass wir in den krisenmodus
kommen jetzt sind wir im krisenmodus
aber nicht fürs klima ja das stimmt
man muss auch total aufpassen dass man
die sachen also die beiden krisen nicht
zu doll vergleicht ich glaube einigen
ein grundlegender unterschied da gerade
der gerade passiert ist dass auch die
wissenschaft gehört wird das was wir
eigentlich schon seit anderthalb jahren
fordern dass irgendwie die politik auf
die wissenschaft hört und eben so
demnach handelt es wird dauerhaft auf
personen wie draußen gehört hat einen
eigenen podcast und er ist der
persönliche berater von merkel so genau
da müssen wir bei der klimakrise auch
hinkommen warum glaubst du ist das so
warum wird jetzt auf die wissenschaftler
gehört und bürger klimafolgen ich ja ich
glaube das liegt so ein bisschen an
unserem eurozentrischen weltbild in der
gewissen weise weil wir momentan einfach
ja wir die reichen europäer in dem sinne
stark betroffen sind von einer krise und
die markise und momentan glauben wir
zumindest noch nicht so stark betrifft
aber zum beispiel die menschen in afrika
die menschen im globalen süden leiden
schon jetzt stark darunter also du
glaubst weil die bedrohung noch nicht
unmittelbar genug ist genau also die
menschen merken praktisch noch nicht
dass die klimakrise akut ist dass der
klimakrise auf sie persönlich betroffen
heisst das wenn diese klimakrise akut
wird dass wir dann aber durchaus in der
lage wären angemessen zu reagieren
das ist leider zu spät aber der
krisenmodus bedeutet gerade weltweit
stillstand locker und ausnahmezustand
mit dramatischen folgen für jeden
einzelnen schulen und viele geschäfte
sind geschlossen unzählige in kurzarbeit
forschungsinstitute rechnen mit dem
größten wirtschaftseinbruch seit
jahrzehnten
[Musik]
wenn ihr euch einen krisenmodus wünscht
und wenn wir den aktuellen krisen modus
sehen dann merkt wir aber natürlich auch
dass die wirtschaft und damit die
gesellschaft darunter extrem leiden
unterschätzt ihr das unmöglich ich
glaube nicht dass wir das unterschätzen
wenn wir jetzt anfangen unsere
wirtschaft zum beispiel umzubauen in
eine nachhaltige wirtschaft er wird
unsere wirtschaft darunter nicht leiden
sondern in der klimakrise ist eigentlich
auch im ungeheuerliches potenzial aber
dazu müssen wir jetzt ins handeln kommen
was wir fordern ist eben dass die
politik jetzt handelt und dass sie eben
gezielt dieser klimakrise auch
entgegentritt und zwar ernsten gegen
tritt dass sie die krise wieder krisen
handelt was jahr um hier als chance
begreift auch für die deutsche
wirtschaft halten andere für naiv
und gefährlich
[Musik]
das kleine deutschland soll das klima
retten da kann ich nur lachen
wenn wir unsere eigene industrie
kaputtmachen retten wir nicht die welt
auch folker seemann hat mir geschrieben
wir treffen uns vor ein paar wochen war
das noch möglich in seinem skiurlaub in
tirol
der erste satz seiner mail eine
kampfansage
es nervt mich das fast nur naive
jugendliche und linke und grüne spinner
zu wort kommen denen es nur darum geht
deutschland zu zerlegen den satz müssen
sie mir erklären
ich finde das äußerst einseitig zu sagen
wir schalten einfach alles ab
atomkraftwerke
wir schalten die kohlekraftwerke ab und
dann importieren wir im notfall später
mal den strom aus polen die 80 über 90%
energieproduktion durch kohle haben oder
vor den franzosen mit ihren
atomkraftwerken das geht nicht noch mal
zu dem satz was meinen sie mit
deutschland zerlegen man zerlegt
deutschland wenn man die industrie
kaputt macht wenn man einfach aufgrund
der energiekosten und aufgrund der
vielen auflagen und schwierigkeiten das
nächste stahlwerk die nächste
automobilfabrik eben nicht mehr in
deutschland baut sondern dahin geht wo
es eben diese auflagen nicht gibt dann
werden wir über einen längeren zeitraum
hinweg deindustrialisiert sein und das
ist das was ich befürchtet
folker seemann 71 jahre war früher im
internationalen bankgeschäft tätig jetzt
genießt er sein leben als pensionär
einmal im jahr ist er hier in tirol er
beschreibt sich selbst als jemanden der
ungern mit dem zeitgeist mit gilt
bei diesen bildern bei diesen interviews
mit den jungen leuten höre ich aber nur
deutschland muss voran und wir müssen
die welt retten und wir haben die
verpflichtung und ich weiß nicht warum
wir die verpflichtung dazu haben
es liest sich immer nur so wir sind
diejenigen die die welt retten müssen
die anderen die folgen uns dann jemand
das ist sowas von vermessen wenn sie
sagen dass sie die jungen leute
vermessen finden weil die sagen wir als
deutschland müssen unseren teil leisten
und wenn das ausland nicht mitmacht dann
müssen wir trotzdem tun was würden sie
vorschlagen also wenn jetzt china indien
aus unserer sicht zu wenig tun heißt es
dass wir es einfach lassen sollten ja
wir können uns natürlich de ist
industrialisieren wir können wieder
zurück zu bauernhöfen ziegen halten sie
das auch nicht die alternative
das wird nicht passieren gerade die
erneuerbaren energien sind ja zum
beispiel auch ein industriezweig in der
windenergie sind mehrere zehntausend
jobs verloren gegangen weil der ausbau
stockt aber allein von der logik hat man
dafür ein diese zahl vergessen wir sind
ein prozent der bevölkerung und sind für
zwei prozent des kohlendioxid ausstoßes
verantwortlich china ist für 30 prozent
verantwortlich die usa für 15 prozent
das heißt wenn wir tatsächlich hier alle
kohlekraftwerke auch sofort abstellen
würden dann reduzieren wir vielleicht
unseren anteil aber gleichzeitig
entstehen 600 kohlekraftwerke neu auf
der erde also warum diese enorme vorstoß
aber finden sie nicht dass jeder seinen
anteil leisten sollte also was finden
sie daran falsch dass deutschland sagt
wir sind für prozent selbst
verantwortlich also müssen wir auch
unseren anteil leisten
ich möchte auf jeden fall nicht das
millionen arbeitsplätze in deutschland
abgebaut werden und in indien oder sonst
irgendwo entstehen das kann ja alles
kommen nicht und das muss man einfach
ganzheitlich betrachten dass auch die
arbeitsplätze hierzulande erhalten
bleiben
ansonsten können wir uns vieles unseren
ganzen sozialstaaten mit sicherheit
nicht mehr leisten
ich will zwei gegensätzliche positionen
aus meiner reportage zusammenbringen
hier ja um hirsch mit der junge klima
aktiv ist
folker seemann der pensionär der vieles
naiv findet und zur vorsicht mahnt wir
treffen uns kontaktlos per videoschalte
ja schön dass das geklappt hat dass wir
uns hier quasi zusammensetzen und
gemeinsam diskutieren
herr seemann sie haben ja gesagt sie
glauben dass es absolutes wunschdenken
absolut naiv wäre zu glauben dass
deutschland die welt retten könnte wenn
deutschland voran geht bei der
bekämpfung des klimawandels weil alle
anderen eben zu wenig tun
warum ihr was sagst du dazu zu diesem
argument ich glaube angesichts der
klimakrise was da auf uns zukommt das
ist absolut notwendig müssen jetzt den
anfang machen sonst macht niemand
und das sind keine leeren phrasen die
ich da sag ich glaube das wissen sie
auch wir haben 28.000 wissenschaftlern
hinter uns wir haben dann kann sein dass
man über 90 prozent über die qualität
des klimawandels ich finde das etwas
druck beim essen deutschland diese ganz
enorme rolle zuzumuten ist natürlich
sehr sehr idealistisch gedacht dass wir
so einen einfluss haben auf alle anderen
wenn wir veranstalten folgen uns alle
anderen ist eine ganz lange gemacht
abschaltung der atomkraftwerke die
kohlekraft in nrw werden sie man das ist
zu spät das ist zu spät wir müssen bis
2030 müssen alle kohlekraftwerke
abgeschaltet haben damit werden auch
noch schaffen kann und das hat der pole
kraftwerken die moment gebaut werden sie
wollen das also relativ easy ist 2030
haben und ich wage eben für den umbau
ist etwas mehr zeit erforderlich wenn
wurde geschafft werke in der welt
entstehen wenn wir die energie auf
google und ausland weiter dort energie
beziehen dann ist der umwelt
ja eigentlich auch nicht bedient ich
kann ihn auf jeden fall zustimmen dass
mehr zeit für den umbau notwendig wäre
da aber in den letzten 20 jahren nicht
gehandelt wurde absolut nicht an wir
leider nicht mehr diese zeit zu handeln
und möchte das nicht tun
das ist jedem menschen mit einer
deflation extrem bedroht und ich glaube
das muss man anerkennen ich muss sagen
ich finde diese debatte wahnsinnig
spannend war das ist genau die debatte
die unsere gesellschaft führt ich würde
gerne noch eine kurze schlussrunde
machen
wir fangen bei ihnen herr seemann an was
würden sie sich von jahre mir und seiner
generation wünschen eine ganzheitliche
betrachtung und nicht nur eine
einseitige jaromir was würdest du dir
von herrn seemann von seiner generation
wünschen dass sie sich hinter stellen
mit uns auf die straßen gehen für einen
schnelleren wandel dass die politik
handelt
die klimakrise in zeiten von corona
können wir aus der korona krise etwas
für die klimakrise lernen
1 zeigen diese wochen jahr wir können
vorsorglich handeln
wir können zurückstecken wir können auf
die wissenschaft hören
[Musik]
aber nur wenn wir uns einig sind einig
darüber ob und wie wir die krise
bekämpfen wollen bei corona sind wir das
aktuell zumindest weitgehend beim klima
stand heute noch nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]